the critically acclaimed hit series
shit's creek has gone from canadian cult
comedy
to one of the most emmy nominated shows
of 2020.
the series earned 15 nominations for its
final season
which aired this spring on pop tv of
viacom cbs property
they include outstanding comedy and the
four main acting categories
co-creator and show owner daniel levy is
up for writing
directing and best supporting actor he
spoke with us about the show's unlikely
rise and why just as it was hitting its
peak
he decided to walk away
15 emmy nominations i know
i it's um i don't really it's not
it does it's not processing to be
perfectly honest people just keep saying
it at me
like i'm supposed to sort of say yes
yeah i know
um it'll never sink in i think i'm
having a heart attack it's what's
happening
you are like 34. i'm basically 29.
after six seasons the rose family has
become
iconic what does fold in the cheese mean
he folds it in
but shit's creek wasn't an easy sell at
first
it's a small show it's not um
something that is particularly flashy
and i think
people didn't quite know what to do with
it alexis you'd like this product
it's all about aging and dry skin oh my
god ew david in the series
the once wealthy roses have lost
everything
and end up living in a motel in shit's
creek
they thought they had it all but it
wasn't until they came to this town that
they realized that they
in fact had nothing at all um and really
needed to learn that
the true joy of what actually love love
can be
dan levy had two comedic legends by his
side
his dad eugene levy and catherine o'hara
i'm walking home the show was picked up
by the cbc
in canada and pop tv in the us
but it wasn't until netflix started
streaming episodes
in 2017 that it really took off best
better than all the rest levy created a
world
where love and acceptance are the norm
dave is my boyfriend and i've never been
happier
in my life as a gay person getting to
tell
um stories about my community um
those moments were really special to me
i think back to even 10
15 years ago i would never have a
even had that opportunity uh let alone
you know be able to get into a room to
even pitch a story where that exists
in a documentary about the show's final
season
the cast received thank you letters from
moms
of lgbtq children we sincerely believe
that shows like shit's creek will serve
as a catalyst to help
change the world into a kinder safer
more loving place for all lgbtq people
to live
when the cameras stopped rolling and i
stopped
sobbing um i did sit down and i read all
of those letters and
and it was pretty remarkable and i think
you realized too
um television when used
for good can affect such an incredible
positive change
before levy was walking red carpets he
was working them
he spent eight years at mtv co-hosted
the great canadian baking show
and was even a correspondent during the
vancouver olympics
so how does that set you up to dream a
television show
oh it doesn't and what you realize early
on as a show runner and particularly
when you're working with a really small
budget
you need to make sure that everyone is
feeling valued he learned that from his
dad
who this month received a lifetime
achievement award from the newport beach
film festival
she has become this absolute living
legend
um eugene i was telling everyone how
you've become this
living legend i mean the clip was the
sweetest
thing i couldn't think of a more
deserving guy he is just
he has led with such uh grace
so for me it was a masterclass getting
to work
alongside him over these past six years
together they found the heart
in a seemingly silly show through
intricately crafted
and charming characters do you remember
the last time you and i chaired an event
the teenage rosacea ball at the sight
regis
everybody in this cast is kind of an
extraordinary physical comedian
david david do you take
well i was sort of genetically gifted
with a set of eyebrows that sort of do
the work for me
um but you know it is a testament to the
act to the quality of the acting
and the actors because it's very hard
to ride the line between comedy and
drama
the hair makeup and costume teams behind
those
outlandish looks are all up for emmys
too the idea that our show gets 15 emmy
nominations and none of us can actually
go
to the emmys is definitely a story line
that i would have written
for moira what is your favorite season
awards at any point have you said to
yourself
maybe i shouldn't have stopped this no
never it's always felt right you know
listen
an idea pops into my head down the line
for a you know a little special or a
movie or
or whatever that might be great i would
love to work with these people for the
rest of my life
that gives us hope the fans well we
shall see
i'm hanging on to that boy am i ever i
love
this show no i love him i love i know
you've watched the show from the very
beginning
but after looking at those clips anthony
i now want to see it every little bit
you chose was hilarious yeah they are
it's an it's an impactfully crafted show
it just it works on the surface because
it's so much fun
but there's so much detail i see it tony
were you saying something
i thought i heard you guys no it's an
incredibly char it's an it's an
incredibly charming show
gayle you got to go home and watch it
tonight and really the power of
of the power of streaming to take
something that had been out there and
had
fans and go from one group of fans to a
much broader one
and now that that that may include gayle
king no and the scene where
the the letters that they got from
parents very powerful
touching